We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P..
Here is a voicemail from a U.S. Marine who
wants to know why do Republicans use us as
props?
Very interesting.
Take a listen.
Hey, David, this is Matt.
Big fan of the show.
So the question I wanted to ask you is, when
it comes to support, it kind of fell on your
chest about being patriotic.
A lot of politicians both use the military
as Ross.
Yes, I might.
I'm a Marine myself.
And I and I see people talking about how Trump
does love the military goes, he'll do this.
He's very superficial things like like hug
the American flag and talk about how brave
the troops are and stuff like that.
My question is to what do you think it is
about the military polling so well with Republicans
when they so do so very obviously use it,
use us as a prop.
The Democrats aren't aren't innocent of it,
but it feels like the Republicans do it a
lot more.
Thanks, David.
Excellent voicemail.
So first of all, let's take this piece by
piece, the things Trump does for the military
are sort of like I got a voicemail a couple
weeks ago from some some Trump is saying,
David, you're Jewish.
Why don't you love what Trump has done?
Trump's great for the Jews.
He loves Israel and he moved the embassy and
blah, blah, blah, blah.
And I had to explain, American Jews are very
liberal.
And nothing that Trump has done helps get
a peace deal done, which for me as an American
Jew.
And it's a it's a foreign policy issue.
I want to see a peace deal.
And moving the embassy from Tel Aviv to Jerusalem
does nothing.
It's just it's it's optics and posturing and
it's the exact same thing with the military.
So then you get to the interesting question,
which is why does the why do Republicans and
Trump polls so well among the military?
There's a couple different things going on
there at the base level.
More Republicans are joining the military.
OK.
So it's not that the military makes people
Republicans, although I'm sure that that happens
to some degree.
It's that you have an organization that attracts
more Republicans, which is why you see the
military tend to support more Republicans
than Democrats in the presidential race.
However, this year, the Republican numbers
among the military are the worst they've been.
I don't know how long, but for a very long
time.
Check out the recent Military Times poll.
So important to understand a bunch of different
things.
But what's important is that you are identifying
that the things Donald Trump does are meaningless.
They are not really supporting the troops,
much like George W. Bush.
Sending troops into an optional war for fake
reasons was not supportive of the troops.
Supportive would be let's not send them into
harm's way.
And I'm glad you're recognizing that.
I hope more of your your military colleagues
will.
We have a great bonus show for you today?
I had the opportunity last night to take advantage
of some of the prepping I had done.
I had a situation come up yesterday where
I was prepared thanks to my prepping.
It didn't go so well.
I will tell you why on today's bonus show,
get instant access by becoming a member at
join Pacman.
Com.